first comic i ever saw live was in drag
who
the british guy eddie israel is i
believe eddie is trans
well at the time he would he would
be in drag and i think right now he's
said actually this whole time i am right
i think it was called a transsexual back
then i believe the transfest i mean that
might have been an old term yeah i think
that's best i think that's the older
term i don't even know when they stopped
using that yeah i mean i was a kid it
was at the blue note yeah oh that's
amazing and my mom took me i had no clue
really what was going on my mom's
scottish and i think she was just like
oh this british guy is really funny and
but that was the first person i saw do
it live and just killing in this jazz
club blue nose is actually a great room
for stand-up when you think is that too
i've actually never been inside yeah
it's kind of it has like a village
underground kind of vibe just like
intimate but um it was the first person
i saw doing and it was weird even at
that young age like i thought it was i
think i thought it was funny that there
was a man dressed as a woman
you might have him for the wrong reasons
no no no no no no i thought it was it
had jokes no no i thought it was funny
like i just i was like as a kid you you
just find these like if my dad wore like
a spiderman costume once i was like oh
it's my dad but he's dressed as
spider-man like i thought it was funny
but then i noticed and i'm like young
young i don't even know why i was
allowed to be there but then i was like
oh these people find what he's talking
about funny and i remember being like
young going like oh i want to be on the
inside of this joke like what's like i
understood
that the outfit was one thing and then
what he was joking about was something
completely separate right like it wasn't
like a gimmick because eddie will just
dress like that and then talk about like
history and culture
and i remember like
there are two distinct memories i have
as a kid where like i felt on the
outside of something i really wanted to
understand one before i knew how to read
i saw my friend reading
and he was just looking at a book and i
looked and i saw the words and i was
like this is so [ __ ] annoying that i
see all these [ __ ] words
and i can't
read out of frankenstein you know is it
really yes get out of here i remember
being in a taxi the monster looks
through the window he's like man i wish
i could read get out of here and then
the kid teaches the people
well you're the monster i'm the monster
yeah oh that's right frankenstein is the
doctor the monster yeah and i remember
looking at that book i was like i really
want to do that and i remember seeing
eddie izzard up at the blue note and
making all these people laugh and going
like [ __ ] i really wish i understood why
everybody's laughing
and i just didn't know enough about like
whatever he was talking about to do it
so yeah i'm curious about bob it's
interesting because prodigies
also friendly booze talks about it is
you can have prodigies in sports music
acting but not writing
and writing and comedy are hand in hand
because you have to live in order to
reflect on experience yeah so you can't
just be taught how to do it where you
can be taught how to tumble play piano
act do all these things writing no
so you never see children prodigies in
terms of writing because they're not
experiencing enough
huh i'm trying to think i remember when
we were younger do you remember that
book that came out it was called say
that
no no no 13.
do you remember this there was like some
young like uh he was a private school
kid i think was like reflecting on the
movie they made a movie about it later
but is it with jodie foster
i'm thinking of something else
evan rachel wood and so not at all
i'm thinking of panic room sorry go on
i don't know i'm just yeah i'm just
trying to think that yeah that that kind
of makes sense like
i think that's and we talk about this a
lot but like with comedy
like there's very few like great young
comics
yeah like something we know people that
are funny and get funny quickly but yeah
if you look at like iconic comics like
eddie murphy was young and funny and he
was an absolute superstar
outside of eddie maybe like freddy
prince or something like that yeah but
like you want to talk about like the
mount rushmore these people were older
joan
joan
pryor carlin even chappelle started at
like 16 but you didn't see a special
until like 27 20. even and then
chappelle where he is now is after the
sketch show and then other specials
right and it's just like having that
that wisdom and having that life to
reflect on
and having that ex yeah experience
allows other people to tap into this
emotion that they're feeling but they
don't know how to articulate well it's
like leveling up right or it's like any
kind of art form you have to build a
skill set in order to truly express
yourself and they do go hand in hand but
you know we see ourselves i believe that
we see ourselves
on stage and it takes years to get to
the to that vision right because you
want to try and eliminate as many things
as you can between your brain and what's
happening on stage same with drawing i
see what i want to draw but it took me
years to get enough muscle memory and
technique to not think about that
anymore
so that's comedy is kind of the same way
yes you can get funny really quickly but
who you know who cares it doesn't mean
anything there's there's a withdrawing
is quite interesting i think that that
peril is good
because i would look back at like old
jokes i want to do like first notebooks
and the premises
or just the ideas
were just as solid yeah i just didn't
have the skill set to pull them off
and i started to learn that and i'm sure
that's what you're imagining when you're
painting something you're like i want
this tree or this character to look like
this and then you start and you're like
[ __ ]
it doesn't look like it yet and then 10
15 20 years later you learned how to do
the shading to create somebody's cheeks
and bones and all these other kind of
structure and that is stand up yeah my
first my first stand-up notebook just
says liza minelli again and again
[Laughter]
and it's come true
you